السلام عليكم
انا سويت اللي علي
معدل الثانويه عالي جدا جدا جدا
[موسيقى]
بسرعه
اخترت هندسه تليفزيون طبيه تخصص رائحه مره
حب
استمرت فيه وانا قاعد مستمر في حسيت جاني
شعور عارفين لما واحد يشتري روحي اشتري
ثوب العيد قبل العيد
يلا ايش اسوي ساعدوني يا شباب
مره ضيق عليك
عاجب الناس ولكن طالع وراك لقيت المحلنقله
العيد جاء وانا جبت العيد
اخترت تخصص
يعني
في المستشفى رائعه
روحي بعدين خرجت كلمني واحد صاحبي قال لي
اسمع في جامعه فتحت بتدرس طب اسمه الطب
المصارعه الثاني
[موسيقى]
ما انت بكالوريوس علوم قلت اصلا عادي
انا عندي بيئه امريكا
بس في شغف ما في شغل اخذ جائزه
المدرسه
[تصفيق]
طيب جميل
عالم طبيب دخلت البرنامج ودخلت اول سنه
عدت ثاني سنه من البريميد من التحضيري
للطب جاءتهم الحقيقه طلعت قرار قالت يمنا
دراسه الدرجه المزدوجه لابد التزام درجه
الاساسيه طلعت بره الطب برست الدكتوراه
قلت
رجعت تمارس المهنه
رجعت تمارس المهنه دخلت لقيت اللي طلعت
الثاني
افضل مكان بيدرس هذا التخصص روح جيب وظيفه
اشتغلت سنه قلت لا التوب صار مره ماني
قادر لازم ارجع
رجعتنا دخلت الكليه كانت هذه المره
الثالثه مره ثانيه عمرك اكثر من 27 سنه
رميت اغراض رحت على كندا على صوت خلاص انا
بقفل الدنيا وراجع لكندا وكل يوم اصحى من
الساعه 12:00 الصباح لغايه الساعه 3:00
طالع في الجوانكون السعوديه جت فتره
الصباحيه قال فين
دخلت الظهر
مسمومه ماني قادر خلاص
ما قدرت انام ليش ما ليش قالوا عمره كبير
اذا كانت الساعه تقريبا 2 في الصباح مشيت
خرجت
الساعه 7:00 الصباح من الساعه 2:00 لغايه
17 طبقات ناقص 31 درجه مئويه وثلج وجزمه
ثلج نزلت نسيت ان انا البس اي شيء بنلبس
بالبرد رحت محطه المترو دخلت يدي من نوع
تتجمد
باذن الله
بس هذا
الثلاث بعيد عن دوامي رحت ورجعت
تفوتك كثير
وخلصت خلصت السنه هذه بالعافيه وبانجح
نجاح مبهرت
ورجعت قبل ما ارجع بعد ما رجعت من الدوام
شفت يدي ورجعت على الدوام
الساعه 12:00 في الليل
كلمت جميع الجامعات الخاصه السعوديه
كل ما تتخيلوه الاكل من الجمال
جروب
الخاص جروب من خمسه سته اشخاص
طيب
فلما انا ليش
اخذتي الموضوع 10 سنوات
يعني جدا الفكره المجتمع هذا اللي هو هذا
النموذج
فكر افكار تعليم
مجموعه من المعتقدات كونها مجتمع الماء
المجتمع هذا قال هادي المحادثه
هذا اللي هنمشي عليه وهنعتبره جيدا وسياسه
المجتمع بنستنى
التغيير والسويت هذا الشيء وجاء بعده ناس
يلا
طيب
لازم اجد منهجيه المشكله
تغيير تغيير المهنه مختلف تماما
والبس مهنه جديده لازم ان انا اعمل خطوات
جديده جدا غيرت منهجتي قلت لازم اعرف ايش
الخطه بالضبط اللي امشي عليها ايش لازم
افهم لقيت عشان افهم المشكله
من اول وجديد واطبق الخطوات السبع لحل
مشاكل اكثر فعاليه لازم اعرف بيئه المشكله
البيئه المشكله اسمها الفكره المجتمعي
السائد ما ينفع تغير لما تعدي سنه معين
انت خلاص الدكتور
خلاص صرت مهندس انت فيك انت انت انت طب
انا ايش احاسيسي ايش مشاعري ايش رغباتي
ايش فيك ايش ايش ايش ايش ليش في فرشه
واحده بلون واحد بندهن المجتمع كله بيها
انت تكون كده وانت كنت كده
تحبنيها بقاعده القاعده الاساسيه ما حغير
الناس انا هغير عقليتي اول تغيير العقليه
قبل ما تغير المهنه
طيب
عقليتي مشاكل كانت عندي
مشاكل العقليه يعني
عقليهتي كانت عندي
متفائل جدا عندي يفر تفاؤل بمعنى ايش
مخيلتي دائما
وناجح وخلاص ارتفاع وصلت مواصيل اتعثر
فلازم اخفض سقف التوقعات لازم اعيش في
الواقع شويه ثاني حاجه عقليه الضحيه
المثلث المدمر للنفسيه والشخصيه
اللون
النقد
والقاتل المقارنه
انا الي انا ليش من اول اسوي يلا ايش الي
خلاك تتاخر عشان خايف من الناس طيب ليش
تسوي في الموصل المقارنه
وانتقد العالم
وكل العقبات وكل الكوارث
هي عباره عن تدريب عملي دوله ربانيه لاصبح
قائد في المستقبل
فرقه معي كثير
تغيير العقليه
لها شقين
انا
عندي حاجه اسمها
اللعنه المعتاد ما اقدر اكون معتدل ما
ينفع اكون مثل واحد عادي جدا لازم اكون
مختلف ما عندي مشكله
ثاني حاجه
خامس اطالع وراء الاقي الطريق صار بعيد
وماني عارف اكمل فلازم تعود على الشيء ده
وابني مهاره اتصال مع نفسي اولا ان اكون
صادق مع نفسي بدر انت ليش بتسوي الشيء هذا
هل عشان يكون عندك
فلوس
في 50,000 طريقه تطلع فيها فلوس الصريح
طبعا تكون لي
كثير ماديه وكل
مبلغ
انا عباره عن منتج استثماري انا حسستمر
فيه حتطور تعليم دراسه
اجتهاد عباره عن نفسه جديد هيكون عندك
تطوير مستمر لنفسي 24 ساعه هذا الشيء عشان
ينتج عندي منتج اسمه الطبيب العالم
ويمكن يفشل المشروع في احتماليه
بعد قد ايه لازم تسوي تسوق لنفسي خطا
للنظام اللي انا قاعد اتكلم عنه اليوم ما
ينفع ان انا اكون نموذج واحد قد يفشل قد
ينجح لازم اتكلم عن مجموعه نظام متكامل من
التغيير
طيب ايش هي
سبب ايش هو سبب التغيير
مجموعه من المهارات مجموعه من الادوات
مجموعه من التقنيات اللي تتطلب مني مواهب
واحترافيه ومهارات محدده مهارات لا تتوافق
مع هذه الوظيفه مهما سويت مهما طورت ماني
قادر اوصل للي فيه انعدام بيشتغل انعدام
ليه الاهتمام انعدام ليه مهما كانت تخصص
ممتاز ورائع ولكن في فاصل كبير بينه وبينه
لازم اناميها مشكلتي تتغير
مشكلتي اني انا كنت بحكم نفسي خوفي من
المجتمع وقافي من الخروج من البرادايم انه
انا كنت بقارن نفسي قدره اليوم لكن اول ما
شجعت وعملت الخطوه لقيت نفسي اني انا مره
ما عندي مشكله اصلا الساعه 05:00 الصباح
اروح المستشفى اداوم اخلص شغلي اذاكر هناك
في السياره اسمع اسمع ال ال المحاضره ارجع
هنا اذاكر اختبر ارجع ثاني اقول ما انت
شويه احاول ان انا اطور من نفسي ما لقيت
ان انا قلت لا ما ينفع ان انا اكون مدخن
لان انا هدفي ما هو نفسي اخلق نظام صار كل
حياتي كل ما تطويرات في نفسي في شخصيه
على دائره زي كده هدفها ان انا اكون شخصيه
جديده في اي شيء يوصلني لهذا الشيء لازم
اسويه تخلص منها اعاده قويه هيكون الطبيب
طيب
بنات بنات بنات بنات
فقط على الهرم على راس الهرم اللي فوق ده
انا عندي
موهبه يحب الطب وانا ابغى اكون شغوف
ما ينفع بموهبتك بقدرتك فقط تصل اي شيء
لازم يكون عندك مهارات عندك عقليه تتقبل
التغيير المستدام عندك عقليه للتواصل عندك
عقليه لتطوير نفسك منتج عندك عاقليه
للتسويق للذكر نفسه وتكون رائد في هذا
المجال وبعدين تحط عليه هذا الشيء اللي هو
مهاراتك الشخصيه
في الاخير حابب اقول انه قصدك مقوله نحتدي
بها جميعا انه لا شيء ثابت في هذه الدنيا
الا التغيير
فقط
[موسيقى]
المهنه والشرف
اصلا صنع جيل يحب ما يعمل ويعمل ما يحب
وظيفه وظيفه وتخصص قد يكون فوق النجاه
والسعاده لشخص او اثنين او عشره ولكنه قد
يكون فوق الاستعداد لك الحل انك ما تقعد
تلون فوق الاستعباد بلونه
علمتك هي يعني هذه الدنيا كامله
فاكرين الجروب اللي قلت لك عليه اللي كان
خمسه سته الان وصل تقريبا خمسه عشره 20 30
50 100000 و 2700 واحد صار عندنا 2700
واحد من ضمنهم في خلال سنتين 163 واحد
ساعدتهم هم يغيروا المجال او يتطور في
مجالهم
سبب بسيط جدا عمل المسبب يعني ان انا اكون
اساعد الناس
لانه انا فكره بدل ما انا كنت
في قاع البراداي في قاع الاستسلام ليه
النموذج الفكر الساعد للمجتمع انا كنت هنا
طلعت منه وجريت النور شويتين لقيتهم مفترق
طريق الشيخ عديت منه طلعت لقيتهم
بديت اخرج بره الفكر وتحرر الين لما يعمل
شيف برا وطلعت الى النقطه الاساسي وشفت
النور هذا هو مش عارف في الحياه انا واحد
التغيير في المجال الطبي